[Music]
in generous winter news submitted by
smooth criminal' a buddhist poker player
won $600,000 at a tournament and decided
to give it all away
i don't think they should be down I
don't think gambling is a lot of
Buddhism I thought it was okay because
people gambled during Chinese New Year
and stuff he's 67 years old from Canada
his name is Scott
he won third place at the PokerStars
Caribbean adventure yeah yeah so he won
six hundred and seventy one thousand two
hundred and forty dollars Libre
but the Buddhist version yeah dragon we
wait he's not no dad there are white
Buddhists I know but I just know when
you think Buddhist oh I think like
straight from China no mana I thought he
was in to be in the orange robe yeah all
out asking first always thinking like a
Shaolin kung-fu master like playing
poker but that crusty is two feet you've
ever seen I love I still type myself
yeah so he was saying that he's gonna
give it all the way he usually gives
away his winnings Oh first time like he
won like so much so he the Buddhist he
translates Buddhist and Sanskrit text to
English he's been doing it for a few
decades so I could read all that stuff
out there yeah wait what's what's
Sanskrit is that - one of the oldest
land oh I think it's like it's like the
Latin of like Indian languages yeah so
it's like it's a dead language but it's
like old school and it's like a root
language for a lot of new ones and I
think cuneiform came before that or it
was like at the same time but those are
the two that are all ancient languages
super old that we can still do some
uniform Sumerian right I think so okay
how can you have such a giving heart as
a human being that is that is I bet II
support ear it was like well being a
practitioner of Buddhism we sit around
and meditate a lot and that's
so he just he probably likes poker for
the game and not really for like trying
to be rich from poker yeah but like it
probably costs him something to get to
Jamaica though like hold onto a little
bit yes I mean he's probably none he's
probably in a comfortable place to be
able to do stuff like that because if I
was millions and then like or not even
millions if I'm doing well and
everything's taken care of I just love
the game of poker and if I won and I'm
like oh you know every year I want to
donate to the [ __ ] fetus I mean
shoeless kids shooters kids world or
some shoes for kids or that feed kids
kids kids I just picture these kids
holding the shoulders of two adults with
dangling with nothing on it
I think I'm understanding Jose mine now
because he pictured bare feet and that's
what came out of his mouth this kids
yeah feel this kid I was like [ __ ] okay
that didn't sound right better than two
hot dicks dude hot dicks is pretty kinds
of too hot dicks
I know Oh got it
we can't just finish eating through hot
dicks I wish I hadn't had any context I
just want to cigarette nods be like yeah
I was thinking of that like Mouse beer
that we talked about like way back in
other ones and a few episodes ago
you stayed about that beer because you
talked about kid through that beat and I
was just like well that looked like it
was like I want to fight more being
honest so Scott here he has been dubbed
the people's hero
for donating his winnings he has
previously donated to Oxfam and Doctors
Without Borders alter he's never won
that much before which I did mention so
he also said that he donated most of his
winnings to a Buddhist nunnery when he
won seventy two thousand dollars at a
poker tournament in Barcelona
and he just says like he doesn't
intentionally travel to these
tournaments like he'll only travel if he
qualifies like online like he does
mainly on oh Emily oh that's dope so
everything's really good cuz he's
winning these satellite tournaments and
he's getting to the finals by skill I
wish I could gamble really well but that
requires somebody to be very patient and
very smart to things I don't have so
that makes it difficult for me and you
have to be like ballsy cuz you guys also
something I don't have I'm a [ __ ] poker
I think is it what room it's a different
role what do you mean what do I mean you
know what I mean maybe what you mean
what you mean what do you I think poker
is different from gambling gambling too
you think there's more scalable mafia
yeah you could see how people's betting
pattern is like okay this guy doesn't
have it now you can see just based off
their movement the way their life if
they're nervous yeah and then the better
that you get like the more they can beat
like you're like so transparent it's
like politics what if I'm high and you
could set up traps and things too it's
like you can uh you can appear as if
you're a weak player so people become
overconfident and then you trap them
when you actually have good cards
interesting or like there's all sorts of
high level game play that you could do
but there's also that variable of it is
still gambling and it's still random you
don't know what you're gonna get right
there's probability but it's still not
oh yeah sure
so that's that's the fun part can you
count cards with poker no no doesn't
matter that we can figure out
probability based off of how many cards
are out and then like you could do quick
mass but can do it but it's not as
similar as counting cards really yeah
it's not like people that don't
understand poker they think a lot of
it's gambling and look but yeah there's
a random part involved but you that's
why you always see the same people at
the final table sure cuz it's so skill
based but the random part of it makes it
where like there's a chance newbie can
beat one of the chips but if they play a
hundred games the champ is probably
gonna win 98 97
and then there's a couple times where
the other person just gets lucky and has
like the craziest cars on the planet
wonder how bad that feels for a
professional professional poker player
to play like to get on a table and some
idiot just comes on and just somehow
when's the whole thing you know who
might be that person Oh Josh Oh
josh has got this please all
free-spirited and he's just like I don't
give a [ __ ] and he plays and he like a
winch and I my last move we went on the
retreat I think he beat me Joe and aunt
they were part of the more experienced
ones in JK and we're the first three to
lose we're like cuz he's just so crazy
such a wild card so he'll like read in
yeah he'll be like three five months
suited huh like it's just it's just so
crazy you're like he gets lucky yeah
I'll watch it like I've watched a couple
of JK party episodes and I look at how
he plays and I'm like that doesn't even
know where he's at right now JK party
and we were playing this game called
password where you have to say one word
to describe the one word that you have
between two people and then for your
team and then he ended up describing
number four guess what guess what it is
number one code name kids next door I
have to be one word I can't even
decipher his mind number he said number
as a clue for this one word which was
China I was like what what I was like
Josh you're so funny it was I want to
see this full get interrogated by poked
by a [ __ ] CIA agent and watch that
guy give up I want to see that [ __ ] what
did you see
what is see hey what's going on oh we
play mafia right now dudes all [ __ ]
sweaty as he ties all undone he's like a
[ __ ] quit yeah I can't break them up
I know I don't know what level training
this is but I've never seen it amazing
what did you see
I'll take the double-double
animal style I can never be on a JK
party with them I would assassinate it I
would just be so [ __ ] frustrated dude
we all have done such a far-fetched
thing you know what I mean it's like
banana well why do you think banana cuz
listen a banana is yellow right and
yellow when you mix it with blue it
becomes green and the Green is a sea
kelp and inside the sea kill a turtle
eats it and shits it up poop to do with
anything that's exactly the reactions
he's gotten from everyone in this room
at one point I cannot watch a JK party
episode it's gonna give me anxiety
huh well what if your next one was an
agent interrogating here alright then
it's just game over
[Music]